[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: OS Login is a
Compute Engine offering
that provides a way to
manage SSH access to Linux
virtual machine instances
using IAM roles.
When OS Login is enabled,
a Linux user account
is directly tied to a
user's Google identity.
This means that a user has
a specific username and UID
in all OS Login VMs and their
project or organization.
With OS Login, you can
also restrict root access.
You can enable OS Login
for individual VMs
or for all VMs in your project.
To enable OS Login
for a specific VM,
go to the Compute
Engine VM Instances page
and select your instance.
Start editing the instance and
navigate to the Custom Metadata
section.
You want to add the
key "enable-oslogin"
and set the value to True.
Then click Save.
OS Login is now enabled
on this instance.
And only users with the
appropriate IAM roles
can connect to the VM using SSH.
Alternatively, you can enable
OS Login for all the instances
in your project by navigating
to the Compute Engine Metadata
page and adding "enable-oslogin"
with the value True.
Once this metadata
key is added, OS Login
is enabled on all Linux
VMs in the project.
You can disable OS Login on
a specific instance by adding
the metadata "enable-oslogin"
to false at the instance level.
You can also enable
OS Login when
creating a VM in the
advanced security options.
We will go over how to do
this in a later example.
To grant a user
permission to connect
to VMs that have
OS Login enabled,
the user must have the
required OS Login IAM roles.
Let's take a closer
look at these roles.
Compute OS Admin
Login allows the user
to SSH into the Instance and Run
Commands as an administrator,
while Compute OS Login
allows them to SSH
without administrative access.
The IAM service
account user role
allows a user to run operations
as a service account.
This is a necessary
permission to log in
to a VM that is associated
with the service account.
You can grant the
Compute OS Login roles
at the instance level
or at the project level
so they apply to all
resources inside your project.
The service account user role
can be granted on the project
or on individual
service accounts.
In scenarios where users
outside your organization
require access to your VMs,
your organization administrator
must grant the Compute OS
Login external user role
to those users at the
organization level.
Let's run through an example.
We will start by creating
a Compute Engine instance.
We are going to leave all
the fields as defaults.
Scroll down and expand
to the Security section.
Here you can see
the Manage Access
section and the option
Control VM Access
through IAM Permissions.
This will ensure that
our newly created VM
will have OS Login enabled.
Let's return to SSH
into the VM as a user
without the Compute Admin role.
And it's unsuccessful.
This is expected
because we have not yet
given the necessary permissions
to this user account.
Let's go ahead and grant
the appropriate IAM roles
to my user account.
In this scenario, we
would like this user
to be able to SSH into the
VM but not on any commands
as the root account.
Therefore, we need to grant this
user the Compute OS Login role.
Now let's try to SSH once again.
Wait a few seconds.
And we are able to SSH
into the VM successfully.
In summary, OS Login can
simplify SSH access management
to your Compute Engine
instances by using IAM roles.
When granting
these roles, always
keep in mind the security best
practice of least privilege.
And set your
permissions accordingly.
[MUSIC PLAYING]